REELED THEM IN OVER THE ICE.
>> Carley: ALREADY HEROES.
>> Brian: THANKS, CARLEY.
TWO DAYS BORDER PATROL AGENTS
HAVE RESCUED TWO 5-YEAR-OLD
GIRLS TRYING TO CROSS THE BORDER
ALONE IN TWO SEPARATE INCIDENTS.
WHY IS THIS NOT A BIGGER STORY.
AS THE CRISIS AT OUR OWN
SOUTHERN BORDER GROWS, PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS DEPLOYING TROOPS TO
PROTECT UKRAINE'S BORDER SO TO
SPEAK OR AT LEAST NATO'S BORDER
NEAR THE UKRAINE.
ARIZONA GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
STEVE GAIN NOR WRITES THIS.
I AM INCENSED THAT MR. BIDEN IS
SENDING AMERICAN SOLDIERS AND
TAX DOLLARS TO SURE UP THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER WHILE ARIZONA
FULL SCALE INVASION CAUSED BY
HIS POLICY.
HE JOINS US NOW.
STEVE, WHAT MADE YOU EQUATE THE
TWO?
IN YOUR COLUMN ON FOX NEWS?
>> WELL, THE UKRAINIAN BORDER IS
SOMETHING THAT JOE BIDEN IS AT A
PAYING ATTENTION TO.
PUTTING AMERICAN RESOURCES AT
RISK.
IT'S A POTENTIAL INVASION BUT
WHAT WE HAVE IN ARIZONA IS AN
ACTUAL INVASION.
WE HAVE PEOPLE POURING ACROSS
THE BORDER DRUGS, TRAFFICKING,
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND IS HE DOING NOTHING.
>> Brian: THESE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS JUST WALK THROUGH.
IF THIS WAS A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO, THIS WOULD BE HOW COULD
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE A POLICY
THAT ALLOWS CHILDREN TO BE
CAUGHT ALONE AT THE BORDER?
BUT, INSTEAD, IT DOESN'T EVEN
MAKE THE RAIDER ON OTHER
CHANNELS.
>> WELL, IT'S MAKING THE RADAR
IN ARIZONA.
WE KNOW IT'S GOING ON HERE.
AND IT'S INTOLERABLE.
WE KNOW PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS
EVERY DAY.
WHEN I VISITED THE BORDER, THERE
WERE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WAITING
FOR THE BORDER PATROL TO PICK
THEM UP.
IT'S AS IF THE BORDER PATROL IS
NOW UBER.
TAKING PEOPLE FROM THE BORDER TO
THE AIRPORTS AND FLYING THEM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
>> Brian: I KNOW YOU WANT TO BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA.
ONE THING IS ALSO CLEAR, YOUR
SENATORS ARE MIA AS BOLD AS
SENATOR SINEMA IS.
SHE NEVER TALKS ABOUT THE
BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW IF MARK KELLY EVEN
WANTS TO BE NOTICED ON
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO.
WHY DON'T THEY CARE?
IS IT ABOUT THEIR PARTY OR ABOUT
THE COUNTRY HAVE ANY.
>> BRIAN, I THINK THIS IS
INTENTIONAL.
THEY ARE FLOODING OUR COUNTRY
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE ILLEGAL.
BUT, AT THE SAME TIME, PEOPLE
ARE COMING IN TO OUR COUNTRY WHO
REALLY, I THINK, MEAN US NO
GOOD.
IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE.
AS WELL AS AN ISSUE IN ARIZONA.
WE HAVE ESCALATING CRIME.
OVERDOSES ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Brian: IN TERMS OF IT
ARIZONA.
WE PUT A LOT OF FOCUS ON TEXAS.
WHY HAVEN'T THE NATIONAL GUARD
BEEN MOBILIZED IN ARIZONA LIKE
THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN
MOBILIZED IN TEXAS?
>> I BELIEVE THE GUARD HAS BEEN
MOBILIZED HERE TO SOME DEGREE.
BUT WE'RE OVERMATCHED.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS, AND
BORDER PATROL ITSELF.
DPS.
THEY'RE OVERWHELMED BY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
ACROSS.
BRIAN, I WOULD ASK YOU.
>> Brian: JUST REAL QUICK, THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS A FEW DAYS AGO AND SHE SAID
THE FIRST THING WE DID AS AN
ADMINISTRATION IS OFFER
IMMIGRATION REFORM AND NOBODY
TOOK IT UP IN CONGRESS.
WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER TO THAT?
>> THE FIRST THING THEY DID IS
OVERTURN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION POLICIES KEEPING
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
AND GAVE THE CARTELS AN ENGRAVED
INVITATION TO BRING PEOPLE IN,
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
I WOULD ASK YOUR AUDIENCE GO TO
MY WEBSITE DANA FOR
GOVERNOR.COM.
WE CAN USE ALL THE HELP WE CAN
GET HERE IN ARIZONA.
>> Brian: YEAH.
YOU OBVIOUSLY COULD.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT OTHER
NATIONALITIES, ARE YOU SEEING
OTHER THAN CENTRAL AMERICANS
SOUTH AMERICA?
WHO ARE YOU SEEING?
>> YES.
WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE FROM
UZBEKISTAN, PAKISTAN, AND
COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME WHEN I VISITED
THE BORDER, THERE ARE A LOT OF
SPANISH-SPEAKING PEOPLE.
NO MEXICANS.
CENTRAL AMERICAN AND CUBANS, BUT
THERE ARE PEOPLE FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD THAT DON'T
BELONG HERE.
>> Brian: COSTS US A TON OF
MONEY.
A LOT IN SECURITY AND PEACE OF
MI